somebody asked you 10 years ago what
would revolution today look like to you
you would have deep racial divisions
media split down the middle
false information narratives rioting
looting protests
and unwillingness of authorities to
either deal with them or an inability to
deal with them we have some or all of
those things going on
i think we have to talk about mcdonald's
first what really happened
we got a call from an informant and says
mcdonald's monopoly games
are corrupted there's a guy named uncle
jerry who's
arranging for winners and stealing
pieces a lot of just
nose to the grindstone investigative
work we went up on a wire tap
tied it all together you were member of
the swat at the 1993 branch davidian
siege in waco texas and you were there
for 51 days
what do you think they need to do to
recover from this and gain the
credibility again
like a business it's critical to have a
good reputation i hope we can recover
from it do you still follow the news of
what's going on or no
you know certain things are stressful to
watch
some of the footage of the rioting and
looting hits close to home
and i was a swat guy i love this could
george floyd's event
have been prevented i think with a lot
of these cops who
really go bad it was always it was
always something there a lot of these
guys
cops are not worried about somebody hold
them accountable
so the question is how did we get here
how did we get to where
every small town police department has
fancy tactical
stuff they fuel the narrative of
defunding the police
[Music]
so today my guess is chris graham let me
let me kind of set this up so you know
how this thing works out so imagine you
wake up
you go to college you get out of college
you become an accountant
and you've taken the safe route and then
all of a sudden an
event happens in your life that you
decide to go from being an accountant to
an fbi agent
and then you do that for 26 years and
then you become a swat
and then you work undercover you do all
these other crazy projects we'll talk
about
and then one day you're a supervisor in
jacksonville
working as an fbi agent for white collar
crimes
and you get a call an informant calls in
and says hey
i think you guys got to look into what's
going on with mcdonald's and they say
what do you mean
there's this guy named jerry jacobson
who apparently has taken 24 million
dollars swindled
24 million dollars over a 24 year period
with the old mcdonald's monopoly game
and that leads to a six six episode
series on hbo called make
millions and today we're talking to the
main character
named chris graham that's going to
unpack this for us and i don't know if
he's going to inspire some of you guys
to want to be fbi agents
or uh some of you guys may never go back
to mcdonald's but we're going to find
out the story here so chris thank you so
much
for being a guest on valuetainment
awesome thanks honored to be here
thrilled so so first of all why from
accounting to fbi i mean
what happened there yeah you know that's
a that's a great question and
and i appreciate you asking it because
unlike a lot of young people today when
i
went to college um this was in
1980 early 80s if you remember
the economy sucked i mean especially
coming out of the 70s
and if you you needed to get a job i
wasn't going to college to
experience anything other than getting
getting some piece of paper that would
land me a job and at the time being an
accountant
was was a way to do it i got out
very easy it seemed it seemed you know
that it came naturally
took the cpa passed it blah blah blah uh
walked into work uh at a big eight
accounting firm it was big eight back in
the day
and i would tell you by lunch on the
first day
i knew i hated it i was miserable and i
needed to get out and do
do something else so being
whatever you know sticking with it stuck
with it for three four years
and at the time the fbi was was looking
at and hiring a lot of accounts a lot
more than usual
because of the savings and loan crisis
in the late 80s and i had some friends
who
who had kind of left joined went into
the fbi
and it just it intrigued me and it sort
of fit you know one thing led to the
other and you know i still remember
first day showing up at at the academy
at quantico
and and just feeling you know this is it
it it it fits i was right at home so
um and then you know looking back now
it's it's
26 years goes by fast um looking back on
it now and looking at all the
all the all the experiences and things
and
you know i'm looking at like plaques i
have on the wall from this
this experience that experience um
you know i i am i consider myself one of
the most lucky people on earth to have
stumbled into that and you know now
you know now can sit back and
and relive some glory days yeah you know
that's the greatest part about it you
know the accidental there was a book
that was written the first apple book
that was written the story of steve jobs
and steve wozniak was called the
accidental millionaire
and they wrote another book about
zuckerberg that started facebook the
accidental billionaire
if you ever write a book you should
title it the accidental fbi agent
yeah well you know and the other thing i
mean frankly growing up around dc which
i did
government employees didn't have a great
reputation
so going that direction was was
completely against
my parents wishes and and some others so
but you're right accidental
just just happened to happen to be lucky
and
watch watch the bank robbery happen once
and that's
that's all it took i i don't think a
lot's changed since the time you were
growing up to now with comey and mccabe
and what's going on today you know how
fbi agents are seen
uh i don't think fbi agents have the
kind of trust and credibility they had a
long time ago
it's a very weird time right now with
fbi agents it's it's a damn shame and
we'll come back to mcdonald's because
you know or mcmillan's i want to talk
about that but i'm glad you asked about
you know about
uh the image and then and now
and like like any business
the fbi is a brand and an image and
we when i started and throughout my
career
we relied on that image to
get access to get somebody to talk to
you to knock on a door
and you're standing there in a suit and
you
people are going to tell you things
because they believe
rightly or wrongly they believe in the
the professionalism of the agency
the trust the the things like that and
and we got
it was critical we couldn't do the job
otherwise
this and and you know i'm not gonna i'm
not gonna
dive into you know who's right who's
wrong comey mccabe all that jazz
it's it's it's a it's a damn shame it
has
tarnished the reputation and the brand
that's going to take i you know it's
going to take years to overcome it
and you know well i will i will kind of
dive into it a little bit
every time the the bureau has had a
a significant national embarrassment or
a problem like this
not every time but but most of them if
you go back and look
most often it has happened when
higher-ups at headquarters who are in in
the ivory tower of headquarters and
believe they still can work cases
and believe that they're smarter than
everybody else and maybe
maybe they are but you know smart is
only part of the
part of the equation to get get a case
done every one of those or almost every
one of those
has been the result of headquarters
taking over control
and trying to run a case and that's you
know that's what went on with
with with co with not so much [ __ ] while
comey was the director
but mccabe strock and all that and you
know
plenty of plenty of agents have a lot
more intimate knowledge about that than
i do but
that's the that's kind of the big thing
and and you know the reputation
like i said it's like a business it's
critical to have a good reputation
i hope we can recover from it so i hope
so that's my two cents
i hope so as well because yesterday just
yesterday
and i know this is a new former cia
officer charged with spying
for china cia that's yesterday and then
38 minutes ago
former fbi attorney pleads guilty and
durham probe i don't know if you just
saw this yeah
came out right now the justice bomber
unusual promoter and so you know
investigation links between trump
campaign and russia netted its first
guilty plea wednesday as former fbi
attorney kevin
kleinschmidt admitted to altering an
email used to seek surveillance warrants
against former trump campaign advisor
carter page i mean this is some ugly
stuff
going on in these agencies what do you
think they need to do to recover from
this and gain the credibility again
you know there's no magic bullet i mean
it's just it's it's
it's stay the hell out of stay the hell
out of national scandals
highlight the good work the great i mean
that's what we try to do with millions
and you know i know we'll keep coming
back to that but
i i think one of the one of the focuses
of mcmillian's was
to highlight a case that was a success
and and and that the agents involved
weren't you know weren't egotistical
[ __ ]
and and and things work the way they
should
that's what it's going to take it's
going to take dozens and dozens of those
cases
going back to the fbi attorney though
let me just i'll kind of defend
when you hear fbi attorney that's
usually a career attorney
who's come in as a as a civilian general
i don't know this but
my mom 95 sure it's not an agent so the
agent ranks
you know that's that's your career
that's all you do you don't you know you
don't move in and out you don't join a
law firm you
that that's what you do so but you're
right i mean the these
the these the case the cia case
yesterday this one today
it's almost it's almost every you know
every week we have one of these and um
you know it's like bad cops i mean you
know you got
nine i i you know i heard you say on one
of your you know your recent uh
your recent talks that you know the bad
cops are
one percent 99 or are good people well
that one percent impacts dramatically
the other 99 percent who are trying to
do
and and generally do the right thing so
okay so you know it's crazy you're
saying that you know when you're talking
about the
you know the good agents on what they're
doing i remember a long time ago a
friend of mine he and i met when i got
out of the military he went and became a
cop
and he says pat i got to tell you this
badge and this gun that i carry and i
walk into a restaurant
changes me it changes people i said what
do you mean
because i saw him went from being a nice
guy got along with everybody and then he
started snapping in restaurants
started losing his cool all the time
like what is wrong with this guy
and eventually he lost his job he lost
his badge they took everything away from
him i said what happened here
he said it does something to you the
badge and the gun does something to you
so
you know i i i hope there is a
resolution to do something because i do
think there is a need for these
organizations out there
to do what they're doing i just don't
think there's any need for manipulation
which is what's happened a little bit
lately so so so chris here's your resume
you you were a you were member of the
swap swat
at the 1993 branch davidian siege in
waco texas which we talked about gary
nestor we had it on you were there for
51 days
you've been to uh deployed to egypt and
later chosen to open uh
the first i believe fbi office in milan
italy handling fbi fba operations there
for three years which i'm sure you had a
good time in italy
you conducted dozens of interviews with
detained al qaeda and taliban leaders
and operatives which maybe we'll get to
that here in a minute but out of all
these crazy things you've done
i think we have to talk about mcdonald's
first for whatever reason
that one's getting the most attention so
so this phone call comes in from the
informant to kind of walk us through
what really happened
was it mcdonald's i heard it was really
a marketing agency and mcdonald had no
clue what was going on
it was more on this and walk us through
with what happened there
yeah so so you're right and and
ultimately it wasn't
an agency a marketing agency but you
know we didn't know that at the time nor
do we know
nor nor do we know the name of the
person who
who was doing this crime so you gotta
let's just kind of put it in perspective
here i've got a squad of
of 10 12 agents and working high
priority
white collar stuff which is police
corruption and
and health care fraud which was a big
big big problem back then
we got a call from an informant to one
of the guys on my squad
and says guess what mcdonald's monopoly
games
are corrupted there's a guy named uncle
jerry
who's arranging for winners and stealing
the pieces
and has been going on forever so
easy enough to say all right what's this
guy's motive i mean what's
you know this is kind of ridiculous how
could how can mcdonald's let this happen
but it's to me it's kind of one of these
things that
if it's true you can't ignore it you you
have to
make it maybe a remote chance but i've
got to run this down
so we start we start getting some basic
information some names of some winners
it all checks out the informant gave us
a couple of names of winners
turns out these winners we were able to
associate them
in terms of addresses and friends and
relatives that's right away now
statistically it's impossible it's
starting to check out
a lot of just and you know we can we can
talk about you know
traditional police work but a lot of or
our investigative work a lot of just
knows to the grindstone investigative
work that went on for a couple of months
looking at phone records
making the connections doing the charts
et cetera
we came to a point where we had to make
a decision
to contact mcdonald's and bring that and
bring them in
not knowing a whole lot of details not
knowing if
mcdonald's is involved if somebody on
their staff's involved
etc the reason we had to bring them in
the main reason there was not a lot of
reasons but we needed to get
you know we needed to get lists of
winners we needed their cooperation
and ultimately we wanted to go up on a
wiretap a title through wiretap well
if you think about it the games are
historical they're past
so somebody's won they've claimed their
prize
and it's over there's nothing there's
nothing going on anymore
by that time we had we had made some
connections through phone records
between
winners between what i call middlemen
and a main guy named jerry jacobson who
you know you mentioned earlier he was
the the mastermind behind this
he didn't work for mcdonald's he worked
for a company called simon marketing
but again we still really know the
the connections between between him and
mcdonald's folks
but back to my point so we've got to
prove up this case
currently historical records are great
but they're not gonna they're not gonna
get us there per se
it's going to take it's going to take
forever we want mcdonald's to run the
game
again but for them to run it
you know why is the fbi telling you hey
we need you to run this game
and we need to be talking to you when
you're running the game
in the context of that they know there's
a problem the games have been
compromised
so if you're you know if you're a risk
management person
or an executive at mcdonald's you are
now confronted with
what i you know i think it's a i think
it's a horrible decision it's like the
least
what's the least worst answer do we tell
the fbi
you know no way take a hike we can't we
can't stomach this risk
knowing that the case is probably not
going to go away we may run with it
anyway
and mcdonald's gets gets named as
they're not cooperating or
we cooperate and we get in bed with them
and we got to live with the consequences
and they did the latter
thankfully and and to their credit
because they paid
you know they paid the consequences
later on with public relations with
lawsuits
etc but we couldn't have done this
without mcdonald's
um i i you know i said in the show
i think we expected an immediate answer
we brought him down we brought him down
to jacksonville we had him in the
in the conference room all the
executives and we said hey here's the
case you know
here's all the stuff we got we need to
run the game again
and we thought well of course they're
going to say yeah why why wouldn't they
we're the fbi
you know our reputation was still pretty
good back then
they're going to they're going to say
yes well they were kind of like well we
got a
we're going to talk about this and off
they went they got on planes and went
back and we were a little perplexed
now i see you know working in the
corporate world
i see exact that was a that was a
massive decision that went all the way
up to their
ceo who again i think made the right
decision
we went up on a wiretap recorded
incredible phone calls
tied it all together we we did some
undercover work which i'll get into in a
minute
but we were even able to tell mcdonald's
before the the last winner the winner
that claimed it during the
you know during the game during the game
they were running knowing it was
compromised
we were able to tell mcdonald's you're
going to get a call from a guy named
brown in texas
who's going to claim to be the winner a
couple days before he did
we knew that because we were listening
on phone calls and we we heard
we heard the passage we actually were
able to surveil
the passage of the stolen piece that's
how it you know that's
jacobson was and i won't get into all
the details but you know
jacobson had figured out a way to
essentially shoplift
the winning piece in route where he was
going to
theoretically place it into circulation
and he would he would switch them out
put a you know a shitty one for french
fries and where the winning one was
supposed to be
hang on to the winning one and then take
uh recruit one of his middlemen to find
a winner who could be trusted
and that the piece would get get passed
we were actually able to surveil
based on what we learned on the wiretap
surveil
jacobson meet with dwight baker who's
who's named in this thing
in the parking lot and our pilot saw him
pass the envelope
uh in the parking lot and then
ultimately we know baker passed it on to
another guy who passed it on to the
winner so big success
a lot of fun um you know
cases don't always we had a lot of
laughs with this case
um and you can because nobody's dying
and
and and we had some fun with it you know
we had a we had we ran an undercover
operation as part of it
which we call the the reunion of past
winners
so we want to get winners from hey pat
you know you won
you won back in 1999 and you know we
want to get you to tell your story again
because and because it's such a great
story
and we're going to host a reunion of
winners
in vegas it's all going to be paid for
we're going to have you in a big
conference room
brilliant you're going to tell your
story but in order to do that we're
going to record you right now it's going
to go on a big screen
and tell us again how you how you want
so we did a lot of that we got a lot of
these people locked into
lies about how they won um we created a
production company was called shamrock
productions
and and the byline was because you're
just lucky which
if you it's a little bit of a little bit
of tongue-in-cheek
humor there but but that was the kind of
you know that was kind of thing and then
what happened
so big takedown national takedown john
ashcroft
uh presented in front of national media
um it was the story all over the weekend
uh actually was uh you know august i
think 21st
2001 was still kind of a story they were
rolling up indictments and and
ultimately
you know ultimately a lot more
indictments but we all know what
happened on september 11th
and that you know that freaking change
that changed everything
and the the the dozens of agents who
were working this
went down to the two guys who had to
carry it through in the prosecutor and
no one
no one heard the story until two three
years ago i got contacted by james
hernandez who was
one of the executive producers of
mcmillian's and he had
he had kind of stumbled on the story and
started doing some research and felt it
was a great
great story i thought personally i was
glad to talk about it because it was
always
it was always one of these stories you
would tell at a cocktail hour or
something you know somebody's
usually fbi they're like hey tell me a
great fbi story and
you need something to kind of prompt it
and i
i would always go to mcdonald's i would
say you know well you know have you had
a mcdonald's lately yeah of course all
right let me tell you about that
so i i was always telling the story but
no one believed it they would ah come on
that's [ __ ] you're you know you're
exaggerating chris
to have james and those guys dig into it
was
you know was really fortuitous i thought
you know i thought they'll get an
hour-long documentary true crime thing
on it
they they did a phenomenal job digging
in
finding a lot more information victims
personal stories other subjects that we
you know we just it wasn't really the
craziest part they found that you didn't
know about you're like holy [ __ ] what
was this all about was the craziest
thing that you found out
through them not you oh yeah that's that
boy that's a great that's a great
question there there's about four or
five things um
they you know if you watch it there was
a so so there was there was
there was a lot of jerry's running
around so we had two uncles we they kept
talking about uncle jerry and there was
a guy named jerry colombo
you know big heavy italian guy who was
married to robin colombo and if you
watch the if you watch
millions she is she's a character i mean
she's
just got to see i can't even describe
her um
she was married to him he claimed to be
a big oc guy
claimed he was connected with some
families and everybody assumed well
that's uncle jerry
that's uncle j well we we eventually
figured out that
there was jerry colombo and then it was
jerry jacobson and they met through
what we believe you know some some
organized crime connection
jerry columbo died um and in a car crash
and
there's some suspicious circumstances
about that but
they they and when i say i mean james
and brian are producers and their their
research team
they got in and they they dug up archive
video about how jerry columbo
was running a a strip joint up in
south carolina that he was all over the
news that
it had been it was they're going to
close it down he was he was going around
around with city council and he kind of
he renamed it as a church so it was the
church of the
the fuzzy bunny or something like that
and he was able to stay open
that was that was just these like little
things that
you know you know what
frankly pat i'm glad we didn't stumble
on that stuff during the case
because it would have diverted us we
would we've been spending too much time
well someone's got to go hey somebody's
got to drive up to south carolina and
check out this fuzzy bunny thing and
we'd have never got to the finish line
yeah you wouldn't have it would have
been a distraction
yeah uh uh depending on the quality of
the bunnies they had but going back to
it so
so you're so you're seeing these stories
and
is is it true that jerry the main guy
ended up being
in the mcdonald commercial was he in the
commercial himself i i saw something
with one of the jerry's being in a
commercial in a video
it was it was the big jerry it was
columbo it was
i forget where it was that was you know
that was another thing that they that
they dug up
now jacobson jacobson the main guy kept
a low profile and if you if you you know
if you watch it or i'm sure that the
listeners watched it
remember he jacobson was a former cop
from south florida and you know
went out on some on some
quote unquote disability moved up to
atlanta but he kept he kept a pretty low
profile up there
um the other one that jerry columbo was
all over
you know he was all over the media now
where is the connection with a mormon i
saw i heard something about the mormon
connection to this what does that have
to do with mcdonald's
so so dwight baker who was one of
jacobson's main we call them middleman
or recruiters so
when you put this thing in we would put
it on a chart and in the middle you've
got jacobson and you have lines going
out to
the the recruiters and the middlemen
because jacobson never he never dealt
directly with the winners obviously
that's
you know if you're a drug dealer you're
the main kingpin you don't want to deal
with a guy on the street you want people
in the middle to distance yourself
so baker was one of the one of the most
the most recent let's say at the time
recruiters
middlemen happened to live very close to
you know to to uh jacobson in south
carolina
uh they were you know of all places fair
play that was the name of the
that was the name of the town they lived
in i mean you couldn't make this [ __ ] up
i mean we just kept stumbling on how
how how in the world what's the chances
of
the the main subjects of this scam
that's all about
honesty and integrity living in a town
called fair play
south carolina but um but i digress
but yeah but he was he was a an elder in
the mormon church
and uh i i think was you know ended up
i'm not sure
you know you would get excommunicated or
or something he's
you know he's in the um you know he's in
the mcmillions film you know
i will say you know this is i i said
when i got on this i said i'm gonna you
know i'm gonna be as candid and
give my opinions uh freely um
there's a couple guys in that dwight
baker is one
and the other one george chandler who
was his i think his adopted son
he was a winner george chandler was a
winner and
dwight baker gave him the million dollar
piece
neither of these guys needed the money
first of all
if you listen to them they they are in
this and
it's they really are working hard to
make themselves seem
um you know sympathetic honorable
um not quite innocent but pretty damn
close to it
especially especially chandler i i
you know i got no room for that um you
know these guys knew what they were
doing
if nothing else they might not have
known and this go
this goes through for any of the winners
they might not have known that there was
a jerry jacobson
up there who was stealing the pieces and
this is who he works and blah blah blah
most of them got stories that hey i got
a friend who got this piece
and he's going through a bad divorce and
the wife can't know about it
so you take it you claim it and you know
you get to you get a hundred thousand
and you know give us the rest of mine
well
okay that's you know you're screwing
somebody
in that deal you're screwing the ex-wife
or somebody so
so this bit about you know all this was
all you know this was all on the up and
up
i'm not buying it the there was a woman
and she's in the um
she's in the series gloria brown uh
african-american lady in jacksonville
was friends of robin colombo
she was a million-dollar winner she
never got she got
a fraction of the money they they made
her made her pay a bunch up front
blah blah blah she got charged well she
didn't have the funds to hire a big
high-priced lawyer
she had the public defender they pled
they pled her out clutter like 50 we had
52 some odd people
in in the in the ultimate indictment
most of them pled guilty all but about
six
um george chandler did not and went to
trial
with an expensive attorney because he
could afford it i i just
to me there's some inequity there and
you know i think
you know if people are watching it it
goes to your point you know you can't
you can't paint everybody with the same
brush there were different
you know if anybody was close to
innocent in this it was
people you know the gloria browns of the
of the world so anyway
that's my you guys can do you think
they're ever going to bring that game
back because i can tell you for me as a
marketing campaign it was
genius because i remember as a kid you
know
i worked at burger king so it was kind
of like well you know i'm about to go to
mcdonald's because i'm going to get
these pieces and
they were sitting on our desk and we're
collecting them it's like what do you
have what do you have
and it was always funny because you
would bring your pieces to school
and there was always one piece everybody
was missing there was
always one piece everybody was
boardwalker park place one of them was
always
no one can get it yeah we're missing
those two and hey what if we team up
together and what if we come together
now we realize all those young 12 13 14
year old kids
dreams were crushed by this jerry guy
uh we couldn't find those pieces but
give us
one last crazy story until we get to the
next one here what's another crazy
findings you saw
uh that happened with this that will
shock the hell out of the rest of us
yeah i think you know they found they
found i don't know if it shocks the hell
out of us
um well no i'll give you two of them so
if you watch it so doug matthews who
everybody loves he was the agent who
worked on it and he he's still on the
job
um he's on film and and
he's quite the character um gets away
with some f-bombs and
and all kinds of other stuff and uh i
knew he was
you know i knew he was a character i i
didn't know he was quite the uh
the the on-screen ham as as he's turned
out to be so
again uh that was kind of cool but now
and then you know they
they the producers found uh jacobson's
son who's estranged
interviewed him he had nothing good to
say about him
um things like that they you know they
they
they took a case and made a story out of
it and that that was cool
that was going and there's a corporate
side to it too you know so you've got
you know i've seen some interviews with
the producers
uh i don't think mcdo i think mcdonald's
had another hard decision about whether
to participate
in the filming and production of
mcmillian's again here's this
here's this nightmare of theirs from 20
years ago
hopefully it's all been forgotten and
now it's come back and
holy [ __ ] hbo is going to do a story on
it wow
that's so but the biggest part for me to
forgive them which
in my mind i was kind of like well what
is wrong with mcdonald's and then it was
it wasn't us we hired a marketing agency
we have no clue what's going on over
there
then as a consumer i'm like you know
what you can't because as somebody that
runs a company i've hired marketing
agencies and
one time i hired this one marketing
agency for instagram made all these
promises
six years ago and i'll never forget it
was myself and a local pastor in la
we were pretty much using the same guy
and they had this machine that they were
doing that was liking pictures
and all of a sudden the hashtags they
had that was liking pictures
here's a pastor getting uh criticism for
liking pictures of nude women and men
and weird random things like wait a
minute we have no idea what's going on
we heard a marketing agency
so it was a very funny yet weird
situation because you still have to
explain yourself
so for me on the macdonald said i'm like
listen if you hired a marketing agency
i can see how something like something
like this could happen it was a
brilliant marketing campaign oh that's
for sure
oh yeah they their revenue their revenue
would skyrocket when they ran these
games
um they're upfront about that it was it
was a game changer
quote a quote a game changer on the
revenue side
chris what's the craziest thing you've
done in your lot of different things if
you were to say
you know i mean interviewing dozens of
detained al qaeda and taliban leaders
what was that like you know
and and i won't i won't get into you
know names and where
but here's what i would say and i
thought about this are they names that
we should know
yes yeah really okay yeah in place
in places you'd know too okay but one of
the things
and i thought about this listening to
gravano and i thought about this too
in terms of interviewing some you know
some like al qaeda leader types
and that is had these guys
wound up working for um you know leg
mason
or or a big firm or a company or a t
they would have rose to the top in those
organizations
as as leaders because they're that's how
they are they're
brilliant engaging smart people
who just have a natural tendency to lead
whether it's you know whether you're in
al qaeda or you're in
la costa nostra or you know
on the good side of the law the ceo of
company that that was
always you know i i came away a few
times from interviews like that thinking
you know wow that guy you know it's a
damn shame it's a damn shame he wound up
you know wound up where he's at now
because you know a couple of couple of
good
breaks he very easily would have you
know could have could have led
you know saudi aramco or something it's
i think
yeah what do you mean by that can give
me give me give me okay go to the person
that you think about without giving a
name and what was impressive about him
when he sat down with him
i think just not not just not just his
history
but the fortitude in terms of overcoming
hardships like bad bad hardships bad
um treatment um
keeping you know maybe maybe keeping
some degree of sanity
um engaging very you know
very astute to um
where we were coming from questions um
funny sense of humor at times which
you know it counts for a lot um
yeah no i i just you could just tell
and and i think i think you noticed this
with like a gravano or these guys guys
who
who who rose to the top of an
organization that
a lot of people get killed along the way
rising to the top if you're stupid
bad things happen to you or you get you
get ostracized
same thing um so when you interview
these guys were you on their turf or
were they on our turf
they're on our turf they're on our turf
when you interview them yeah and is this
after they got caught or is this
nothing's happened yet and they were
willing to sit down with you
you know i've i've i've done both okay i
i've had the
i've had the you know the the pleasure
to do the pleasure that
the whatever you want to call it the the
opportunity to do a little
little of both little both um you know
and yeah no [ __ ] there's there's others
out there who are
you know maniacal savages and you know
and they're you know they're where there
are but um
yeah it's interesting very interesting
being where you are right now watching
do you still follow the news of what's
going on or no are you following
everything or not really not at the pace
you did before
i probably follow it i'm selective about
it so like what
you know what kind of you know i'm
i'm conscious and cautious enough about
what i watch
to know that you know certain things
are stressful to watch and
taxing and don't don't add to
learning now watch what do you not watch
you know i i mean i i think
so i work in corporate security now for
for a mall company
so so some of the some of the footage of
of the rioting and looting
hits close to home it really does and
you know
we've we've lived that and can continue
to live it
so and and by watching i'm talking about
not just tv but social media
so you know i think some of you know
some some video footage where you're
getting
part of the story or it's being spun a
certain way
um i i i'm cautious about about that and
and
you know i think you brought it up on in
one of your earlier talks
you got to consider who's you know the
motives of people behind this
so i i think you you said you know is
isn't doesn't it make sense that china
benefits
or russia benefits or the middle east
benefits from
the these scenes of chaos in the street
i
you know hey it's going on and that's
unfortunate
but riling riling people up in an
emotional state by watching it on
on a screen hundreds of miles away
doesn't really doesn't really help the
problem it's certain and i'm hey i'm
selfish i'm always looking out for
you know my well-being and it doesn't do
me any good to to walk out of the room
with high blood pressure because of
something i
you know something i saw um makes sense
as an fbi agent yourself what are your
thoughts about this whole defunding
police situation where
you know you're getting commissioners
that are resigning and you're getting
patrick j lynch president of the new
york union is coming out and saying for
the first time ever we're coming up
publicly and saying we're supporting
trump
and it's it's a very weird dynamic where
you know
some are being criticized some you know
seattle's just deciding to fully defund
and go completely different direction
what do you think about what's going on
there yeah no it's it's it's
incredibly complicated obviously
obviously blanket calls to defund the
police are
a reactionary i mean do we want do we
want new york to return to
the way it was in 1974 no i don't
you know i don't think anybody anybody
would agree with that um
you know i think changes have
changes probably need to be made um
here's where i'll go with this and i i
made some notes to talk about it one of
the things let me kind of go back
and and i'll tell you i'll tell you kind
of the where i'm going with this
so 2015 we had the tragic shooting in
san bernardino
uh at the uh it was like a community
center
guy was you know guy was a terrorist and
you know we you know they had been him
and his wife had been back and forth to
pakistan a few times
terrible shooting right fifty you know
14 15 people killed
the worst of the worst i'm watching it
on the news
it's it's over right they they caught
the guy he's down on the highway
somewhere
the guys who or the police officers who
who stopped him were you know patrol
guys highway patrol guys they end up in
a shootout with
them the footage on tv is
dozens if not hundreds of fully armed
swat guys walking up and down the
streets of san bernardino
with long guns with all the equipment
with all the fancy gear with the armored
trucks all that [ __ ]
so keep that in mind i ran i ran a i ran
a
jttf a joint terrorism task force uh
for you know last last 50 whatever 10 12
years of my career
and the thing that's missing in in
that image of the san bernardino is
you've got
all these guys and millions of dollars
of equipment thrown at something
that having them all out there after the
fact
is it doesn't prevent it what would what
would have prevented it you got to ask
yourself
how would where could we have spent
those resources
to potentially prevent that and it's not
you know
it's not and i was a swat guy i love
this [ __ ] i mean i you know i lived it i
when i was into the scene you know hey
man run shoot
jump work out what get paid for it man
that's
that's a great deal get fancy equipment
you know it's almost like in
in the fbi it's like in high school
right there's you know extracurricular
activities and then there's the guys on
the football team and they're the swat
guys right so
you know you got a little bit of that so
i was there i get it i understand
i understand the need but but looking at
it from
a law enforcement executive or manager
all those millions of dollars for sexy
and fancy equipment
wouldn't have been better to go into the
salaries
and and and of analysts and and
software and you know the intelligence
work
paying informants all that stuff that is
not sexy
it's boring as hell many times it
doesn't
pan out to anything you may prevent
things you don't even know you've
prevented them and i know
i i know we've done that just just by
having a presence
interviewing somebody through some
intelligence so
this goes to my point the the broader
point which we see today
and that's this you hear this concept
it's it's kind of come into vogue lately
um i'd like to think i you know i was
one of the pioneers of thinking about it
not that i
not that i raised my voice about it but
this this militarization of police
and you know and and you see it now
where you've got
um it it drives a wedge
in in a community where you have what
looks to be an occupying military force
now no doubt about it you need to have
you need to have swat teams here and
there in big cities deal with an active
shooter
etcetera but and and so the question is
how did we get here
how did how did how did we get to where
every small town police department has
an armored vehicle and a team with long
guns and maybe a helicopter and all
kinds of other
again you know fancy tactical stuff
and and i can't take credit for this is
coming from a guy named
bradley balco who wrote a book it's
called you know the rise of the warrior
cop
and he points to the the funding
two to two sources military surplus
stuff under a program was a 1033 program
where local state local law enforcement
could go to the military and say
hey we need an armored vehicle you got
any extra ones well yeah we just brought
a whole bunch of them back from iraq so
take it take it wrong with it so now
they got an armored vehicle they might
get other stuff
and then post 911 you know dhs
funding grants to have this kind of
preparation and if you're
you you're given the choice you're
running a small police department
and you've got you know you might be a
sheriff or something and you've got
voters you're trying to impress city
council
you're going to spend that money on a
fancy team that can repel out of
helicopters even though you're never
going to use them
or i'm going to hire you know i'm going
to hire three kids
with phds in computer science and
analytical intelligence to grind through
records or i'm going to hire you know
i'm going to hire
investigators or agents who are adept at
work in informants who might have the
language who who can get into
these groups that's where i think we've
got to we've got we've reached that
point
and you know and to my the broader point
i think that those images of fully armed
police departments
have have been counting they've been
counterproductive they fueled the
they fueled the narrative of defrock
defunding the police
so by the way i like which a lot of
people are not going to agree with me
but that's
it's fine i i understand that's the
whole reason why we're having a
conversation i'm reading a book right
now called the man who saw
the market how jim simmons launched the
quant revolution the guy's worth about
24 billion dollars
and uh when he came out he
started a company and hired i think was
working for some university and he ended
up hiring the best
mathematicians in america and eventually
in the world and he brought him together
and eventually he started a firm
and he brought all these mathematicians
to study the market to see what happens
with the trends
then he figured out a formula i think he
ended up averaging 65
return over a 20-year period which is
insane to be thinking about that kind of
a money
and no wonder he's worth 24 billion
dollars today but he hired
mathematicians
a lot of that today's predictive
analytics so what you're saying today
makes a lot of sense on
making those investments to see if that
can be prevented here's a follow-up
question to you
could george floyd's event have been
prevented could that have been prevented
yeah i mean i think the i think the
obvious you know the other
you know i'm just i'm just kind of
parroting you know things i've heard and
read
throw maybe a little common sense on it
you know you've got you've got an
officer who
has a history of discipline problems you
you
i've heard people say and even good
friends of mine who
you know we've talked and they're on the
other side of this issue and they say
there's
there's a thin blue line there's a blue
line of silence
so you see maybe a little bit of that
with the these these other officers
putting up
with with george that's what says not
floyd what's the the officer's name i
forget um
derek are you talking about there yeah
there so so they put up with him they
know he's they know he's a hot head
they know he's a problem and and they
you know they choose
hey we got to go we got to get along
we're all part of the same team here
and we're not going to say or do
anything because that's just not
what we do that you know how do you
break that
well and i'm not i'm not holding the fbi
up as an example
but within the fbi if you are aware
of misconduct by somebody
or you know they they violated some
policy procedure you know their their
their
violated computer pro thing or their or
their acting out
there's something there's something
wrong and it
it blows up into an issue a disciplinary
issue or something like that
and and and they they the investigation
the internal
determines that hey chris graham
you know you knew you know you knew that
pat
had a habit of of of really yelling at
people and
and and he hit this person once on the
back of the head during an interview
you were there you know that's against
policy you saw you didn't do anything
guess what you're in just as much you're
not maybe not in as much trouble but now
your career is on the line
and i think some police departments have
variations of that but but you've got to
make it so and you
you take the personality out of it so if
if
you know i can say to you know to you
all right hey
hey pat you know i had to tell them what
i saw
it's not it's not personal i don't have
you know
but i gotta look out for my career i
can't you know
i got a family to feed i think if you do
that right
i know but you got to take it out of
that you've got to make it hey
i didn't want to be it i didn't want to
you call me a snitch i didn't
the agency the same agency we both work
for the same agency that pays our salary
put these requirements on me just like
they put them on you
saw something i expect you to to say
about me
yeah how much sensitivity is that you
know how you see these movies and in the
movies they show
a bad cop two bad cops and a good cop
the two bad cops go and rob a guy of
cocaine and 200 000
of cash and they decide to split it and
the third guy doesn't want to take it
he's like dude i don't want to have
anything to do with this you almost see
the other two guys
doing whatever they can to put this guy
out and they're worried about him being
a snitch and his career is pretty much
done right so there's the pressure of
almost not accepting
now this is hollywood's i'm not in the
world to know what happens
it almost seems like there's pressure
for the good cop
to also participate in the bad behavior
because if you don't
it can end up you know turning on you
and you got a reputation coming back so
i guess what i'm trying to ask here is
so we have derek shogun right the guy
who put the
knee on george's neck for 8 minutes and
46 seconds
what what do you do to see these trends
and say listen because i'm telling you
when i'm telling you this friend of mine
was the calmest guy
we'd go to nightclubs he would talk to
girls like this hey
what's your name so this and he was so
smooth he was so chill he was the
calmest guy i knew
when he became a cop then all of a
sudden he went more like this and like
this and one day
we went out started telling people off
hey [ __ ] maybe
i'm like i've never seen you talk like
this before what happened to you
and i said i sat him down one day i said
the son will tell you something i'm a
little concerned about she said what's
why is that
i said i don't know what the hell is
going on with you but you acting like
the world owes you something and he got
emotional he said pat i'm telling you
this badge and this uh
gun is doing something now this is
coming from a guy that was in the
military for three years
hunter for airborne division had a saw
weapon had an m16 i mean i'm telling you
from a
guy who was in the military and but i
saw it did something to some people
how do you control and be able to read
somebody about to go the direction of
being a bad cop bad agent how do you
catch that what are some signs to look
for well i got to ask you you know
you've known this guy you said you knew
him before he was a cop oh yeah
nicest guy in the world nothing there
was nothing in his personality
nothing nothing he was a sweetheart from
a
loving family mom and dad never got a
divorce my parents got a divorce so you
could have seen my temper and said
well it comes from his this this but
nothing was raised in america went to a
nice school had her brother they got
along
he was with the same girl since he was
16 years old
nothing happened with them he loved her
she loved him david what the streak of
how in five years
boom like this i couldn't understand it
i i'd like to i'd hopefully like to
think he's just the anomaly
and that you know i mean
but what you're saying so so based on
what you're saying you're making me
think
that a lot of the part of having a derek
chauvin is in the hiring process and
the background should present where
you're going oh
you weed them out in the hiring process
you know a lot of these a lot of these
they do site tests things like that i
think some of these background
you know the background stuff usually
pretty cursory right i mean they're not
getting into
hey pat you know you knew this guy you
knew this guy in
middle school um you know did he ever
did he ever get in a fight
you know did what do you remember about
that did that that kind of that kind of
background fair enough so what questions
give you red flags so ask me the
questions
what are some of the questions that
would give you a good scoring
on your entire predictive analytics why
this is this guy we can't hire this guy
this guy's a little bit of a
loose cannon you know you i've watched
some of your interviews and you you
should probably should have been an fbi
agent
because you do a great job of of two
things right
you you have your facts but you listen
and often it's an open-ended question so
i mean i
i can't off the top of my head come up
with like specific background questions
but
if i'm you know i'm i'm doing a
background on
derek chauvin he's getting he's ready to
get into the police department
and you're you know you're his best
friend you've known you've known him for
forever you went to high school to get
i'm just you know i'm using this
hypothetically
i'm gonna ask you just talk about him
tell me about him
and you know oh oh he played
you know he played linebacker um you
know tell me about how he played
and just try to work off of that and get
you know get
bits and pieces into a personality and
hopefully
you know hopefully something comes out
not always it does i mean you
your friend's a classic example i mean
something must have happened on the job
or
or there was something late in there i
think many of these you know many of
these guys
there was always clues it's just like
you know it's it's like when somebody
turns out to be a pedophile or
you know or something you know somebody
shoots them up people come out oh well
yeah there was always something a little
you know if you really press it there
was something about that guy
i think with a lot of these cops who who
really go bad
there it was always there was always
something there now that said i've had a
couple of i've had i have friends
and the job changes there's no doubt
about that that
you know you work in a you know you work
in a in a difficult environment where
the the community does not like you and
and you are a sign of bad things i mean
when
when you know [ __ ] i get nervous now i i
get nervous when i get pulled over and i
got no reason to i
you know it's not you know so
you're people involved in that
environment
it takes a toll on people and the
the the it's how they deal with it and
crazy
is there tenure in pd and fbi and all of
that all those different organizations
there such a thing as a tenure or no
you know most police departments i i
they have some but not
you know i think it varies it varies
from department to department i mean i i
you know i know guys who are still
police officers into their
you know late 50s and 60s fbi you're out
the door
you know you're out the door at 57 and
you're no no what i'm asking is what i'm
asking is
like a 10-year model of you know how
teachers after 10 years you know they
can't get fired and
you know you have to like really a 42
year old teacher has to
you know make a pass at a 16 year old
boy or girl to get fired
is there 10 years in lmpd and in fbi
well a lot of the pds remember our union
so the the rank and fall
patrol officers are have union
protections so that's
that's effectively you know the same as
as tenure
um so that first of all this this then
this brings up the negative power of
uh union and negative effects of union
because for me like i look at some
teachers okay you see these videos of
some teachers i got terrible attitude
towards kids
but there's nothing you can do about
them you can't fire them because they
have tenure
i think one of the best things that
there is in business
is there is no tenure if you're in a
company you screw up in your 12th year
you can get fired you know
i'm a ceo of a good sized company if i
mess up i'm fired it doesn't matter what
i do
i can be fired as a ceo and i think that
element of not having to fear
cops teachers fire you know
fbi agents not having that fear of dude
if i screw up i could get fired
i'm locked in we're good i can go around
and push people around
the way it's also set up and the comp
structure and the way it's set up with
the protection for them
i i also think um there's an element of
it where for me it's kind of like
nowadays
you know cops are going around working
with criminals and
they're doing their job some cases
they're doing their job
and they're they're the ones constantly
being held accountable rather than the
other way around so there's a fear of
dude i don't even want to do anything
because
they're going to say racism and i'm
going to get arrested but i think
there's also the other part where the
way the format is set up with
accountability
a lot of these guys cops are uh you know
not worried about somebody holding them
accountable yeah i i don't disagree
i mean i think that's one of a number of
factors
leadership you know the culture and
leadership within a department
makes makes a big difference um
back to the you know back to the uh
derek coven and and floyd
one of the things that and i just i just
happen to remember this i want to bring
it up
you know they worked at a nightclub
together right i don't i haven't
really scrubbed into that but you know
floyd was floyd was doing security there
uh derek was was doing off-duty police
work
um guys i know who are
you know a good friend of mine nypd
detectives
washington d.c they will tell you
that is a that is a venue for trouble
for
a law enforcement officer is those kind
of nightclubs because
you know first of all you're getting
paid you get usually getting paid pretty
good
to sit outside your patrol car stand at
the door there's
yeah you find me you find me a club like
that where there's not some illegal
activity going on where there's not some
drug dealing and some prostitution going
on
you got to look the other way and it is
it is an environment that
you know that that sucks people in
um you know if it's a if it's an adult
entertainment
if you know if it's a strip joint
there's you know there's young strippers
around
guys get tangled up in there so i i just
think and
you know maybe i'm wrong i just wonder
you know what kind of history did those
two have
back you know from back at that club was
there was there a beef over
you know over over a drug deal was there
a beef over
you know some some you know some girl
somebody was screwing
i don't know but i i just know from
watching it firsthand and plenty of
friends who are cops
nightclubs strip clubs those kind of
places
put a cop in a bad position yeah that
makes sense
uh final question before we wrap up
chris what's your biggest concern right
now with the current climate we have in
america
you know i here
i've used this before and people people
ask me
hey what do you think of you know what
do you think of what's going on
and i say if somebody asked you and this
is extreme
i get it but if somebody asked you
20 years now somebody asked you 10 years
ago what does revolution look like
what would revolution today look like to
you name
five things that that would entail
revolution i mean it's not like
you know it's not like the the
revolutionary war where they got the red
coats and we're you know we're fighting
it out over
you know bunker hill or anything like
that but name five things
you would have you know deep deep
racial divisions rioting looting
protests
false information narratives media split
down the middle
groups occupying zones and
and an unwillingness of authorities to
either deal with them or an inability to
deal with them
my guess is had somebody asked that if i
had asked somebody that question
you know 10 years ago they probably
would have named a few of those things
and maybe something else and i'd say
well now
what do we have we have those we have
some some or all of those things going
on
it's it's it's pretty damn scary
because you know revolution is a is a
strong word
um so i'm
there there's part of me that's
optimistic i mean you know there's
always the things are
things always seem to work out but but
this this just seems
it seems tough um you know i think
i i've even had personally i've even had
conversations with
people who and and i'm not i'm not
politically
leaning big time one way or the other
i'm i think i'm probably part of the big
bell curve in the middle
but i am former law enforcement and i
you know i lean that way
where i've had conversations
that have my intent was to let's find a
middle ground here
let's you know we're friends we can talk
through this
that have i've walked away feeling
feeling pretty shitty about it because
they went they went
they didn't go well that that to me is
that's really concerning that you know
that people who
family members even that have
you know bound by blood or been friends
forever that
that these conversations that they can't
you know that people have conversations
and
people leave upset that's
that's the you i just i kind of worked
my way into your answer there
the the answer well that's what concerns
me
that makes sense i mean it is uh weird
times it's divisive it
seems like there's two gangs but if you
look at the numbers
42 percent of republicans are not going
to move they're going to vote right
44 percent of democrats are not going to
move they're going to vote left
four percent of the green and the
libertarians are going to stick to their
guns that's about 90 percent
it's the 10 percent that's going to
elect the next president that's simple
as that it's the 10 percent of america
right now that's going to elect
either biden and kamala or uh trump and
um
pence and that tell me tell me who you
think that 10 is
who who you know because like i'm
probably in there somewhere
i think i think you're probably in there
based on which i don't know you
well but based on what you're saying is
you're probably a center-right person
you're probably somebody that's
center-right
uh uh i'm military i'm also center-right
myself but that ten percent
you know you got the entrepreneurs who
may be
socially left but economically they're
conservative
okay so they're going to be kind of
sitting there saying let's see what's
going to be happening over here
you got the uh uh you know the baby
boomers
who may be socially conservative
but economically a little bit liberal
because they need the medicare medical
they need the health they need all that
other stuff so they may vote for
somebody that's going to take care of
their health insurance
so that's a big audience with baby
boomers 76 million of them
you have you know the folks who
don't follow any politics and could care
less but they'll they're willing to vote
and they're just
kind of going to vote quite frankly on
the simplest thing like who they like
more and it's not even that complicated
but that 10
is going to determine our next president
and that next president the next four
years
one is planning on taking capital gains
to 15 percent
which is trump and the other one is
going to plan on
taking taxes to a whole different level
at a higher level so economically you
know
that's going to hurt and who that's
going to benefit and uh
one just said the other day to cardi b
that he wants to make college free for
any family making less than 125 000
of your income for their kids which
that's 90 of them
and uh uh i mean taxes are going to be
going up the way we're going right it's
such a dramatically like when bill
clinton
became president i voted for him i was
the first president i shook hands with
i'm like dude
okay i mean he's a capitalist this is a
yeah we human newt made it work similar
to what reagan and tip o'neill made it
work reagan antipolonium two irishmen
would go out and
hash it out and come back and come up
with something and they would talk [ __ ]
to each other privately and publicly but
things out you know things kind of
cleared up right now it's very weird
it's
very very weird yeah we are today so i
don't know what's going to happen we
will see
my goal today my main outcome of this
entire interview was one thing
my goal was for you and i to be able to
solve every single problem in the world
i think we failed so
i i don't think we solved every problem
in the world but i think we're
starting the conversation and people can
start having a conversation with each
other hopefully in a civil manner
so uh we can get some more clarity but
chris
thank you so much for taking the time
for being a guest over here with us
how can people find you by the way what
is it should we just put the link to
drive it to your website or where would
you like people to come and get a hold
of you yeah so
you know i um i have i have a sort of a
website and it's
it's more of a hobby fun it's called
gmanresources.com you can put it up
there
it talks a little bit talks a little bit
about me um
lean more on the entertainment side what
i'm you know what i'm
doing and working on a couple of a
couple of projects that hopefully will
be uh be entertaining maybe not so much
as mcmillions but
worth watching it's got some stuff about
my story that i
i i wrote over time and wrote that more
to answer you know people people ask hey
what about the fbi what was it like i'm
like well just read
you know read read the my story part i
try to make it a little entertaining and
fun but that's
yeah that's i'm around i'm on linkedin
um
we're gonna put all those links below
look if if you're if you're
you know subtly dropping a marketing
campaign or alluding to a
new documentary coming up about the
church of the fuzzy bunny i'm sure
there's going to be a big audience
that's going to want to learn more about
the church of the fuzzy bunny but if
it's just
other things we're going to put the link
below to your site we're also going to
put the link below to make millions
so uh if you haven't seen it it's on hbo
you can go watch that as well the six
uh series of uh that documentary with
mcmillians and aside from that chris
thank you so much for being a guest on
value team and i really enjoyed it
yeah likewise patrick i enjoyed it
thanks for having me look forward to
talking again soon anytime take care
make millions now one guy named jerry
takes down 24 million dollars over 12
years
with this monopoly game that mcdonald's
comes out with and this 26 year fbi
agent
very very interesting stories to be
thinking about if you enjoyed today's
interview with chris there's two other
interviews i want you to watch one is
with
joe pistone aka donnie brasco if you've
seen a movie if you've never watched his
interview
he's the one that took down five
families and he wasn't informed he was
an insider for
undercover for six years and the other
one is
an interview i did with another fbi
agent mcgowan
who went up and negotiated with the
sinaloa cartel and his stories are
crazy on a whole different side if you
want to listen to this click over here
if you want to listen to joe person
click over here and if you've not
subscribed to the channel please do so
thanks for watching everybody take care
[Music]
bye
you